el día de Navidad millones de personas
en Estados Unidos tuvieron que quedarse
en sus hogares para soportar el intenso
temporal que azota al país el 60% de la
población recibió algún tipo de
advertencia las temperaturas cayeron por
debajo de los estándares habituales
aquellos que violan las previsiones de
conducir pueden pensar que pueden ir a
la tienda por ese pack pero están
poniendo en peligro a otras personas
porque nuestros arados estatales y del
Condado han estado ahí fuera
sin parar perdiendo tiempo y poniéndose
en peligro
Es peligroso Conducir a través de
tormentas de nieve segadoras para
despejar caminos
el temporal desató toda su Furia en
Búfalo Nueva York con vehículos
cubiertos por la nieve y miles de casas
a oscuras por falta de energía los
servicios de respuesta a este tipo de
eventos se han visto paralizados casi
todos los camiones de bomberos están
varados desde el sábado por lo que las
autoridades pidieron a las personas
quedarse en casa Y respetar de repente
porque alguien quiere ir a la tienda
visitar a un amigo o tomar fotografías
de la nieve ahora están varados y
tenemos que expandir nuestras
operaciones de emergencia nuestro
rescate también pero hay una pérdida de
vida sustancial significativa y
devastadora como resultado de esta
tormenta de invierno
es posible que el temporal continúe
miles de vuelos han sido cancelados y el
aeropuerto de Búfalo permanecerá cerrado
hasta el martes